a recently approved medication for
alzheimer's disease is making headlines
because of its price tag 56 thousand
dollars a year i talked to a brain
health researcher at unlv who says this
medication is just the beginning of some
big advances in medicine
47 thousand nevadans have alzheimer's
disease it's the sixth leading cause of
death in the nation we're really dealing
with a disease that we have to respond
to until this summer it had been nearly
20 years since the fda last approved a
medication to fight this epidemic now
some promise the pharmaceutical industry
invested
42.5
billion dollars
to get that was the investment from 1995
to the time adu helm was approved the
drug which is given intravenously
activates the brain's immune system to
remove abnormal protein buildup but it
comes at a price 56 000 a year per
person dr jeffrey cummings a research
professor with unlv's department of
brain health says it's not unusual to
see that initially that's a high price
it is very similar to what
people are paying for cancer drugs right
now otto helm only slows the progression
of mild impairment but dr cummings says
this is just the beginning right now we
have to use scanning
to diagnose the proper patient well it
looks like we're going to be able to do
that with blood tests very soon that's
another reason he speculates the price
of attalhelm will eventually go down
there are these other drugs that look
like they're working as well two of them
have already been submitted to the fda
and you know competition is going to
force that price down we feel like we've
turned the corner that we have we're in
a whole new era of alzheimer's disease
well if you couldn't tell from dr
cummings he is very excited about this
new research what's happening what
they're doing at unlv and lou rovo here
it's really incredible it's very
exciting any breakthrough the more
breakthroughs the better of course so
every little breakthrough is a good
thing